monday september 1st 1890 this is most
likely the date we'll begin our
adventure in the wizarding world when
hogwarts legacy is released and now that
we have that specific date we can take
the knowledge we already know from
sources of harry potter canon and
combine that with information we've
received directly from avalanche and wb
in the form of official trailers blog
posts and the website faq pulling the
original lore together with this new
information will help us get a much
clearer picture of the 1890s wizarding
world the challenges wizards face during
this time period and potentially even
some of the major plot points we'll be
encountering in the game we'll start by
taking a look at what avalanche has said
about the wizarding world and where they
see their story fitting in the overall
mythos of jk rowling's wizarding world
of harry potter for this we'll go
directly to the official faq on the
hogwarts legacy website there are
actually seven questions relating
directly to story and lore listed on the
site all of them contain significant
answers but none more so than this one
will hogwarts legacy adhere to wizarding
world lore
yes while hogwarts legacy is not a
direct adaptation of the books and films
the games are anchored in wizarding
world lore avalanche is creating a
unique gaming experience that is
inspired by the magical universe created
by jk rowling's wizarding world in which
players will find new and unexpected
locations characters and story elements
so here we learn two important things
one it's clear the game will be anchored
firmly in the wizarding world we all
know and love this is backed up even
further in a recent developer interview
we really want to make sure that
anything we add or anything we play with
anything that we explore
really feels authentic the second thing
we learn is that avalanche has been
given the creative freedom to explore
new elements introduced that are
creations of their own but still fitting
into the lore we already know being able
to put our own spin on what this
universe is was a pretty big deal these
points are further driven home and yet
another faq question which reads how
does hogwarts legacy fit into the harry
potter wizarding world while port key
games are not direct adaptations of the
books and films the games are firmly
rooted in the magical universe of the
wizarding world while remaining true to
jk rowling's original vision portkey
game developers chart new territory by
creating fresh ways for fans to immerse
themselves in the wizarding world now
that we've established the developers
intention to have these games firmly
rooted in the wizarding world we know we
can begin to set the stage for september
1st 1890. broadly speaking the late
1800s were a time of increased tensions
within the wizarding world largely due
to their ongoing disagreements and how
they should co-exist with muggles while
human wizards and witches struggled with
how to balance their magic in a world
mostly populated with muggles they also
struggled in their relationships with
magical creatures particularly the more
intelligent beings like goblins and
centaurs ultimately we know it was this
period that led directly to the rise of
gellert grindelwald and eventually tom
riddle who of course became lord
voldemort there are three specific
wizarding world events prior to 1890
which helped to set the landscape for
hogwarts legacy the first would be the
creation of hogwarts itself in
approximately 990 a.d by now potter fans
know the story of godric gryffindor
helga hufflepuff rowena ravenclaw and
salazar slytherin all too well they were
known as four of the greatest wizards
and witches of their age and had a
collective desire to make the world's
best magical school but disagreed in
which students should be permitted to
learn magic this of course led to
slytherin leaving the school but also to
him creating the chamber of secrets
before he did so you see the 10th
century was not a happy one for those
who performed magic as many were
persecuted by muggles for their magical
abilities in the years before 100 a.d
muggles and wizards lived mostly in
harmony with many religious and
political leaders of the time actually
practicing magic themselves but over the
next thousand years or so that
relationship deteriorated and more
muggles began to grow jealous and fear
wizards and this leads us to the second
major wizarding world event that happens
before hogwarts legacy the establishment
of the international statute of
wizarding secrecy which went into effect
in 1692 this would eventually lead to
the formal creation of the ministry of
magic in 1707. throughout the harry
potter series we see numerous ways in
which the wizarding world goes to great
lengths to stay hidden from the muggle
world for our hogwarts legacy timeline
of 1890 these precautions wouldn't have
been as entrenched as they are in harry
potter's day but they would have had
more than 180 years to grow accustomed
to having a governing body like the
ministry of magic and adjusting to this
new way of life that saw them keeping
their magic secret from muggles while
the balance of wizarding and muggle
relationships was the primary challenge
for wizards in the years leading up to
hogwarts legacy it certainly wasn't the
only one which leads us to the third
major event which is actually a series
of events throughout the 17th and 18th
centuries all surrounding one particular
issue of course i'm referring to the
goblin rebellions there was a number of
violent goblin rebellions across these
two centuries with goblins who were
fighting against what they saw as
discrimination and prejudice from
wizards and witches one rebellion that
took place in 1612 happened close to
hogsmeade which saw one of the inns
there used as headquarters for the
rebellion this particular conflict led
to a clause being added to the code of
wan use which was passed by the wizards
council a group that governed britain's
wizarding community prior to the
establishment of the ministry to state
that no non-human creature was permitted
to carry or use a wand this law would
only further contribute to the problem
and helped lead to more rebellions one
revolt that began in 1752 led to two
ministers for magic losing their
position it took a seasoned aurora and
has faced us gore taking over as
minister to put down what was a
particularly bloody revolt one which
even saw werewolves fighting on the side
of goblins gore showed little sympathy
for werewolves that fought on the side
of goblins but many believe this stance
only led to further attacks in the
coming years while we don't know every
detail about what happened in the years
after to help cool the tensions with
goblins and other creatures we do know
that grogan stump played a key role in
helping to improve wizard relations with
creatures and beings stump served as
minister for magic from 1811 to 1819 and
helped to pass key legislation that saw
the creation of the being beast and
spirit divisions within the department
for the regulation and control of
magical creatures stump helped to settle
what had previously been a long debate
in the wizarding world over which
creatures should be considered beings he
decreed that any creature having
sufficient intelligence to understand
laws of the magical community and to
also help their responsibility in
shaping those laws should be treated as
beings rather than beasts in addition to
stump's efforts as minister it's also
safe to say that the ministry returning
full control of gringotts back to the
goblins in 1865 certainly played a role
in placating them as well we learn a
great deal about the relationship
between goblins and wizards and harry
potter and the deathly hallows
particularly in the trio's interactions
with griphook over the sword of
gryffindor which was of course made by
goblins here we learn that the goblin
concept of ownership is very different
from that of wizards bill weasley tells
harry that to a goblin the rightful and
true master of any object is the maker
not the purchaser so given that
gringotts itself was founded by a goblin
there's no doubt the return of it fully
into their hands in 1865 would have been
seen as wizards merely restoring what
was rightfully theirs in the first place
when it comes to wizard and goblin
relations throughout the harry potter
series there's still much we don't know
which could also be seen as plenty of
opportunity for a game like hogwarts
legacy to explore further one thing that
is clear is that neither party is
completely innocent in the matter and
this takes us all the way up to
september 1st 1890 when presumably our
adventure in hogwarts legacy begins the
headline from the daily prophet appears
to be questioning the validity of
another possible goblin rebellion note
the use of the word gobbledagook here as
it's actually the goblin's native
language while the trailer itself talks
of a possible goblin rebellion the
playstation blog post from community
manager chandler wood appears to
outright confirm the rebellion is
legitimate it reads your ties to an
ancient magic put you on a collision
course with a goblin rebellion led by
ranrock aided by his alliance with the
dark wizard victor rookwood who both
present formidable threats to the entire
wizarding world and then later to
unearth the mysteries behind ancient
magic and stop ren rock's rebellion
you'll need a friend and mentor to guide
you along the way inter professor
eliezar figg whose investigations into
rumors of a goblin rebellion have earned
him an uneasy skepticism from the
ministry of magic and so we're
introduced to three characters all of
which are certain to feature prominently
in hogwarts legacy let's talk about
professor figg first he's described as
accomplished and enigmatic yet it would
appear those in the ministry aren't
taking him seriously which will
undoubtedly draw comparisons to harry
potter's era when the ministry didn't
want to believe in voldemort's return
the trailer clearly wants us to see fig
as an ally worthy of our trust but
long-time potter fans will no doubt
treat both fig and the ministry of the
day with a heavy dose of skepticism
until we're able to learn more about
them while many believe eliezer fig
could be a likely ancestor for arabella
fig from the harry potter series i'm
undecided as avalanche appears to be
spelling fig with only one g whereas
arabella fig's last name was with two
g's i don't think this instantly debunks
the possibility of the two being related
but i do think it's worthy to note one
scene i found particularly striking in
the trailer is this confrontation
between professor figg and ranrock my
guess on the location here is gringotts
and the two goblins alongside ranrok
appear to be security officers but what
i found most interesting here is that
it's professor fig who appears to strike
first
not ranrock of course there's much we
still don't know about this particular
encounter such as why fig and the main
character are here in the first place is
this an escape or possibly a break-in as
for ran rock he shows he's plenty
powerful even without the use of a wand
and i've seen a number of theories
popping up already about if there's any
significance to the armor he's wearing
here and even the potential for magical
properties within the armor itself the
blog post appears to confirm he is in
fact leading a rebellion but we don't
know why narrative lead moira squirer
does share a bit more about ranrock's
motivations which reads as follows
ranrok has seen a glimmer of a magic
that wizard kind tried to hide even from
themselves and he wants that power in
particular his worldview is skewed by
his hatred of wizards which makes his
alliance with victor rookwood
particularly tenuous once ranrock gets
what he wants no one will be able to
stop him and the wizarding world will be
doomed there's certainly a lot of
information in just a few short
sentences here first we have it
confirmed that ran rock hates wizards
which means his alliance with rookwood
is a reluctant one and likely born out
of necessity we also learn this power is
something that wizards have tried to
hide even from themselves but more on
that later the trailer also shows a
specific interaction between rookwood
and ranrock
you said you could get to the child when
they came to hogsmeade they're all you
needed was a distraction i gave you a
distraction i just watched a student
take down your distraction
who is this child you're not telling me
i think it's likely the distraction is
the large armored troll we see in the
trailer here as it appears to be
crashing through buildings in hogsmeade
note the red eyes which appear to denote
corrupted creatures by a magical force
and yet for reasons we don't know ran
rock doesn't appear to be fully
comfortable in going after the child on
his own but instead needs rookwood's
help we also learned that rookwood isn't
privy to rand rock's full plan as he
doesn't appear to know about why the
child is significant and speaking of
rookwood we don't know much about his
motivations here other than the blog
referring to him specifically as a dark
wizard and yes i do think it's highly
likely that known death eater augustus
rookwood is one of his descendants we
know that augustus rookwood worked in
the ministry of magic as an unspeakable
which are witches or wizards who worked
specifically in the department of
mysteries is it possible victor also
worked in the department of mysteries
and maybe was even involved in the
cover-up of this ancient magic that ran
rock is after and this brings us to what
is undoubtedly a central plot point for
hogwarts legacy as well as a key
gameplay element ancient magic we know
the main character has what is described
in the gameplay trailer as being an
unusual ability to manipulate powerful
ancient magic hidden in the wizarding
world there are two things we know for
sure about this power one wizard kind
attempt to hide the power and two
ranrock wants this power based on
squire's comments we can also infer two
additional pieces of information one
being that this power is so significant
it actually risks the destruction of the
wizarding world in the wrong hands the
second point is that ranrock appears to
believe he has a way to harness this
power for himself or somehow convince us
the main character to join him the first
hogwarts legacy trailer also had what i
think is a very important line relating
to ancient magic there is a larger world
beyond these walls a world filled with
dangers you cannot yet imagine and
ancient magic long gone from this world
that strange and mysterious talent you
possess may be the key to unlocking this
dormant power your potential is
limitless it's the wording here that's
particularly interesting as it almost
seems to imply there are multiple powers
note how the narrator says that strange
and mysterious talent you possess may be
the key to unlocking this dormant power
so is the strange and mysterious talent
somehow separate from the dormant power
the phrase ancient magic isn't entirely
new to the lore of harry potter the
harry potter lexicon describes ancient
magic as magic that is triggered by
events and powers endemic to the nature
of reality it is extremely old and
mysterious and a wand is not necessary
for it to work and the avatar the player
has the ability
to sense it
and possibly wield it or control it
notice the sequence we see here in the
gameplay trailer as the narrator talks
about our relationship to ancient magic
we see what appears to be a portal that
when touched by our character with
nothing but their hand turns to stone as
if the portal itself was never there
there's also this scene here where our
character joins professor fig in what
appears to be a room with many of these
portals it would seem to me the main
character's strange and mysterious
talent could very well be one of
detection an ability to reveal ancient
magic and in turn the location of powers
that have been left behind perhaps the
ancient magic we unlock is actually a
collection of powers left behind in the
wizarding world by a powerful witch or
wizard such as one or maybe all of the
four hogwarts founders or perhaps even
merlin and that our character possesses
the ability to detect and find these
ancient powers the wizarding world
attempted to hide the specific ancient
powers we can unlock appear to manifest
in different ways we see two in the
gameplay trailer as the narrator says
you can even use the mysterious powerful
magic your professors do not understand
to obliterate your strongest foes the
powers appear to manifest visually with
this black and white effect we see here
as our character uses a dash ability
that almost appears as a form of
short-range apparition followed up by a
spell that calls down lightning from
above this concept of multiple powers
that can only be unlocked by the main
character would also fit with ranrock
wanting to control and use this power
but he needs us to lead him to it
game director alan tu said the most ever
present part of the wizarding world is
its magic and the playful nature and
realness of its distinct rules should
fuel a surprising dark mystery that
tests the combined resources of those
who discover it given the numerous
twists and turns throughout the original
series it should come as no surprise
that devs at avalanche are wanting to
tell a story with an air of mystery and
one of the biggest mysteries we have so
far is why our character starts hogwarts
as a fifth year you are a new student
who is starting at the famed school of
witchcraft and wizardry as a fifth year
which is very unusual
so already there's a bit of an edge and
a bit of a mystery squyrer says players
will get to experience what it was like
for harry starting at a new wizarding
school and knowing no one at all and
like harry the player's character is a
bit of a celebrity from the outset due
to the fact that they are starting as a
fifth year and because they survived her
before she stopped short of answering
the fact that our character knows no one
at all combined with the fact that we
have special activities at school to
help us catch up with other students
leads me to believe our main character
hasn't grown up in the wizarding world
and i'm also inclined to believe that
whatever we survived is what somehow
unlocked this latent magical power
within us this video is likely the first
of many on the story of hogwarts legacy
and how it will build on the wizarding
world we've all come to know and love if
you're looking to brush up on the lore
of the original series there's no better
source than the books themselves you can
download any of the seven harry potter
audiobooks for free by taking advantage
of a 30-day trial from audible.com and
you can even keep the audiobook if you
cancel the free trial also if you're an
amazon prime member you'll actually
receive two audible credits with the
trial which you could use to download
two harry potter books and again keep
them even if you cancel before the
30-day trial ends if you're interested
use the link on your screen now or find
it in the video description below as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon